at the airport today I was selected for
additional screening and the agent
riffled through my books I guess to see
if I had stuff hidden in them I had
three books with me I had some John
Berger I had some Philip bump but I also
had this new acquisition
do you know how hard it was for me to
get this book it's banned the only way
to get a copy is to find someone who
snatched one up before the threat of
legal action ceased its publication
here's the thing though this book
contains no words however the further
you get into it the darker it becomes
you might notice that it's titled 50
Shades of Gray but it's gray with an a
not an e this is not the 2011 erotic
romance novel by El James it is an empty
book by shed Simone it's literally just
50 Shades of the color gray arranged in
sections of decreasing brightness
unfortunately Random House thought that
his title was too similar to their title
so they sent some of a cease and desist
and he complied which means this book
has become very hard to find